not bad for a running back
but yeah um officer long did a great job
i didn't have i barely had pressure um
she was did a great job of getting open
catching the ball it's going to touch
down that's what it's all about and
that's what we did today
[Music]
lamar jackson with a stellar performance
on sunday for the baltimore ravens in
the first game of his second season one
of the obvious surprises of week one
will it make the list of today's draft
and the draft most surprising story from
week one peter picks first chris picks
second and uh i guess that makes me
third peter you're up
lamar jackson throws more touchdown
passes five than he has rushes three
the baltimore ravens and greg roman have
turned this quarterback who everybody
thought was bobby douglas go look that
up kids who everybody thought was bobby
douglas into a real legitimate threat
from the pocket
yeah hard to argue that i think that
might have been my first pick too i mean
we all we were talking about was oh this
run game from the ravens this run game
from the ravens and it was anything but
the story of the game it was all about
lamar jackson's arm and his accuracy and
some of those deep balls and everything
like that i did check the rule book guys
the the dolphins are allowed to put a
free safety in the middle of the field
from time to time to stop some of those
bombs i checked it it is legal okay my
my next one i think i'm going to go to
dallas with kellen moore i think that's
the surprise of one of the most
surprising things i saw in week one i
mean we talked so much about the dallas
cowboys the teams built around the
o-line oh kellen moore he's unproven
what can he do he's only learned
undercut
under um their last oc i'm blanking out
his name mike what the hell is his name
scott lenahan
thank you very much i mean what can he
bring to the offense he's not he's a
first-time play caller and what he
brought to the office was a whole new
fresh look and aggressive passing plays
down the field play action passes that
were phenomenal kept the giants off
balance on first and second down like we
haven't seen from that cowboys offense
and then just that dak prescott and the
weapons that are available to him
randall cobb gallup amari cooper it was
phenomenal so i got to say kellen moore
and that passing offense for the cowboys
one of the most surprising things i saw
from week one
you know it's funny after the game
kellen moore told reporters that jerry
jones had always called him keelan moore
and he said now he calls me kellen i
think he'll be calling him mr moore
after what he did for the offense week
one i gotta go back to what we talked
about not that long ago with what
happened in cleveland the titans blowing
the browns off the field and i know that
that it all fell apart in the fourth
quarter and it was a close game in the
third quarter but to see
43-13 is jarring as the outcome of the
week one game between the tennessee
titans and the cleveland browns people
were pegging the browns for the playoffs
and putting the titans at the bottom of
the afc south and mike vrabel has shown
that he has that ability to coach his
team into a spot where they play up to
the level of competition the danger is
they also play down to the level of the
competition they need consistency but
for week one the titans looked great and
it was a stunner to see them number one
even score 43 points in any game but
also to beat the browns by 30 points on
their own turf yeah hard to argue that
mike you're right that was definitely uh
one of the shockers of the weekend i
mean we were all tuned in to see obj
landry and baker mayfield it didn't work
out so good
peter i will start round two i'll start
round two and i'll give you this one how
many people thought
that the cincinnati bengals
uh who you're right mike we've talked
nothing about them through the entire
offseason but particularly andy dalton
who everybody wonders is he going to be
one and done with zach taylor the new
coach his first game in a new offense he
goes to the hardest place in the nfl to
play seattle he throws for 4 18
without aj green
that is my number two pick yeah that was
that's definitely one of the story i
mean i think most people thought they
were going to get run out of the gym you
know on sunday against the seattle
seahawks and it was anything but that it
was the seahawks hanging on by the skin
of their teeth and that was good for
zach taylor he tore that defense up with
andy dalton okay um i'm gonna go with
last night the raiders the raiders are
the raiders offense i'm gonna go just go
with the whole raiders organization i
mean come on i gotta give john gruden
credit all right i mean yeah okay he
built some of this you know dysfunction
that they've had there over the last or
the whole offseason with antonio brown
yeah is he responsible for that but he's
also responsible for his team coming out
last night and playing very good
football playing tough out competing the
broncos really there was no point during
the game where i thought ooh the broncos
are in control of this they might come
back and win this the writers controlled
it from get-go and really never
relinquished that and i got to give john
gruden credit uh and then oh antonio
brown what's this offense going to look
like oh it looked damn good because
derek carr looked damn good he was on
point and they showed they still have
some other weapons in the offense to go
along you know with derek carr darren
waller there the tight end here's a
rifle down the middle for the touchdown
on the first drive third and one bomb
call bombed over the top by john gruden
they got to give him credit for that
they did a great job the raiders and i
didn't expect them to win and they won
and they one-handedly
now i expected them to get blown off the
field because i thought there were too
many distractions too many issues with
antonio brown and remember they were
saying last week when when everything
was in flux all the coaching staff is
preparing as if antonio brown is going
to play everything's fine friday it
looks like he's going to play saturday
all hell breaks loose i got to give john
gruden a lot of credit for getting these
guys focused yeah on the task at hand
there was a lot of this going on right
knock on wood if you're with me they
were with him last night all right uh
hey the this this was the the stunner to
me of uh the week beyond the the titans
blowout victory when we walked into the
viewing room on sunday we were having a
discussion about all the backup
quarterbacks in the nfl and it was
pointed out by james kaminsky that the
jaguars back up is gardner minshew ii
now this was before the games even
started and we all had a big laugh
gardner minshew the second one snap away
from becoming the jaguars quarterback
and within 90 minutes gardner minshew
the second was the jaguars quarterback
and he completed 22 of 25 passes 88
percent completion right now it came
against the kansas city chiefs so you
know it's not like you're going to pull
out the victory but
there's hope now there's this weird
vague sense that you know with nick
falls out maybe this gardener minshu kid
who had who finished fifth in the
heisman voting at washington state last
year maybe he can make something happen
for the jaguars the players believe in
him they traded for josh dobbs yesterday
to be the back up to minchu so it's not
like they're going to throw minshew
overboard for someone else kind of
intrigued by what gardner minshew can do
and chris i know you didn't like the
wyatt hurt mustache that aaron rodgers
had minshu's got it baby and i hope he
keeps it and mike uh he was impressive
like you said i because of the way he
played it gives me hope that they can
still savage to see salvage the season
until nick foles get back we know they
got a defense they're gonna have to run
the ball he's not nick foles but he
certainly was good enough to move that
offense that game was 23-13 and they
were driving and getting ready to score
again and leonard fournette fumbled on
the 20-yard line and that's kind of when
the wheels fell apart so uh that was
encouraging for sure peter you're up
right next pick i want to see who you
got here
yeah i'm gonna take the atlanta falcons
absolute no-show job damn you with 10
minutes left
at minnesota they are down 28
nothing
i mean how is it possible that matt ryan
with the intergalactic numbers and julio
jones with the intergalactic contract
and a defense that's supposed to be
pretty well fortified how are they down
by 28 on the road in the first game of
the season with 10 minutes to go the
this was
this was i you know when i wrote this on
monday i don't want to put
dan quinn
in the in the in the hot seat after one
week but all i can say is
this is a 500 team
since they lost to the patriots in the
super bowl a 500 team
and they don't have and they do not have
an owner
who wants to be the owner of a 500 team
so
the atlanta falcons better turn it
around
man i'm mad at you why did we invite you
on the show today because that was gonna
be my third pick and i'm so mad i was
gonna start well use adam vinatieri then
that was a good one actually did not
even write that down that is actually
very good don't help him peter you know
what i'm going to use herbs i won't use
it but yes i was going to go with matt
ryan too because that was a shocker of
the day i mean he laid an egg their team
laid a egg really like dan quinn said in
all three phases it was not good okay
i'm not gonna do that even though the
vinatari one's good good i'll leave that
for you mike in case you want it cause
i'm torn in between bears offense and
josh allen because if you told me josh
allen was going to be down 16 points in
new york on the for week one i would say
ooh that's not good but i think the
biggest most surprise still to me is the
bears offense i mean the bears offense
mitchell trubisky year two in the system
matt nagy oh you know offensive he's
getting on that realm and with the
conversation where everybody thinks ooh
he's one of the best offensive play
callers in football got weapons around
him you know just so much talk about the
offense in general and not that i
expected it to go out there and be the
greatest show on turf and have 550 yards
and be all over the place but to lay an
egg the way they did and then only
scored three points yeah that was a
shocker to me i mean yes and i know
green bay played good defense but
they're just too much talent and too
good of a play caller on the bear side
for that for for me to have ever believe
that they would only score three points
on the opening game of the nfl season
now i was ready in this spot to
take the vikings having kirk cousins
throw the ball only 10 times on sunday
and that would have given me an
opportunity to say the vikings have
finally figured out how to properly use
kirk cousins
possible
i said it yesterday it would be
mean-spirited to say it two days in a
row but you said it anyways you said it
anyways though okay that was kind of the
point you're the master of nuance let me
tell you that geez uh so i'm going with
the sunday night game what the hell who
expected the patriots to blow the
steelers off the field chris you thought
the steelers were going to win the game
the patriots they start slowly the time
you want to get them is in september the
pre-season it's not enough time there's
not enough time to get these guys ready
they're never ready they're not ready oh
they were ready on sunday night and
either either these are the same old
patriots and the steelers are just
really going to be horrible this year or
the patriots are already in post-season
form week one of the 2019 regular season
guys
yeah they were i mean hold on look part
of that story sorry go ahead peter park
part of that story has to be the fact
that you know no matter what anybody in
pittsburgh wants to say you know the the
missing antonio brown in the last game
of the season against cincinnati and in
the first game of this season against
the new england patriots they haven't
shown they could be explosive without
antonio brown so that is a huge huge
task for them to get ready to do or else
they're not going to win that division
hey and i agree with you peter you know
a lot of passes thrown by ben
roethlisberger uh that we're missing the
mark and you didn't see a lot of that
with antonio brown and these other
receivers have got to step up or it's
going to be a long year for pittsburgh
are we going to take a break uh and and
put the recap on the screen i don't
think i have time to go through it all
but for anybody who's watching on tv
they at least will get a chance to see
what our picks were and we'll post the
full video at profootballtalk.com as
well if you missed any of it i think it
was a good draft today i think everybody
did a good job let's call it a draw a
three-way draw if that's even possible
when we return i draw more about that
out of here
okay i won the monday night football
game between the raiders and the broncos
one of the stunners from the draft and
uh well the fact that the raiders held
it together really is surprising we'll
talk more about that right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports